old pennoni semi-benoni
oh old benoni is like c5 on move one
maybe if my phone plays d4
i could play that maybe i'll do random
viewer too i know there's been a lot of
a lot of people who aren't subs that are
looking for a game
i'll do random viewer so uh
good luck to this person
derouv ooh two plus eight interesting
okay uh blindfold goes on
good luck to my opponent to roof and
goodbye
so i'll play the oh wait no
uh do i have to play like this now
i can't hear the moves i can just hear
when moves are made
i have to turn on the thing to
temporarily look
opponents deep in thought
okay
speech sorry about that c5
yeah it's two minute blitz because
there's um eight seconds
oh bishop f4 interesting
let's um let's take
c takes d4
queen takes d4 next e6
okay queen a4 queen a4
queen a4 okay i'll play e5
it's a pleasant opening i think i'm
going to try and win
as quickly as possible
no mercy
let's go for the center control
[Music]
f6 probably going for d4 eventually
knight a3 d4 yeah wasting no time
c takes d4
d4
so knights on e3 queen on a4
uh let's deliver a check i typed bishop
g5 i meant to play
bishop before
yeah white has two legal moves king d1
or bishop d2
i'll play bishop f5
man i'm smelling some fun things here
but how to actually execute
i think i'll play rook c8 first rex
so king's on d1 bishops are doing such a
great job
um maybe 94.
oh no my queen
someone should call an ambulance but not
for me
okay i i was waiting for the opportunity
to do this
if the rook wasn't on c1 it would run
away
okay well thanks for the game deruv
did people what was the prediction
oh was the prediction wait what was the
prediction
was the prediction whether or not my
queen would stay on the board
that's so funny if it was
white's queen survives yeah
i did lose a queen but i made up for it
it was a very like quick very quick oh
no my queen
okay nice that was a nice prediction to
go along with that game
so if this goes on youtube hello to
youtube
uh i don't i don't know if this will go
on the clips channel or the main channel
an but not for you yeah
um no need to call an ambulance for me
i'm perfectly fine
managed to bounce back after losing a
queen
hey youtube oh yeah hi youtube
almost broke my headphones there uh
if youtube youtube say hi to twitch chat
say hi also which oh which clips channel
if you use eclipse command
just type exclamation point clips
and this might be it might end up being
very meta but we'll see
anyway we'll leave this going for a
little bit longer
twitch always so positive on their their
best behavior
uh also i'm gonna go extra matter here
so i found i found the youtube
commenters
they have a response to twitch chat look
at this look at this
they're saying hi back at least a few of
them
i just filtered for high twitch so now
you guys can communicate
but maybe asynchronously